[Musique]
la dynastie des kim
résumé des épisodes précédents
le prince lui lui volant au secours de
la princesse nadine amouk fait une chute
spectaculaire en s'échappant de la
forteresse du mont lui temps quel état
tu sais pas si il est importante pour
lui le tchétchène mcit facture est quand
même plus temps passé qu'est ce que tu
vas faire maintenant mais je vais aller
au centre héliomarin hier pour retaper
un peu ils vont voir si j'ai pas des
séquelles c'est le centre des stars la
ballue lui vend surtout si je pars grist
également comme ça toute ma vie changera
pas beaucoup toutefois en plaisantant
tout cas je l'attaqué parce que c'est
pas possible qui me poussait à 60 ans
alors qu'on me dit partout un passé au
moins 130 jeu l'attaquant justin je
m'arrête devant lui puis comme ça on
prendra un petit peu de blé puis te fais
pas de soucis value du j'ai promis que
j'allais travailler je vais aller
travailler
je suis venir à nos besoins je fais pas
de souci j'y vais tout de suite
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
la bourse ou la vie
je veux bien la gauche si j'allais vivre
je suis encore tombé sur une enclume
q je suis mort n des bois le justicier
sauvage
j'ai envie d'embrasser sur la bouche et
rebbie qu'est ce que tu fais je suis le
justicier son ouvrage je vois le vent
les pauvres pour donner aux riches mois
les corrige lui c'est petit robert
l'intellectuel du groupe à et bon élève
des breloques à supposer que tu as là
d'aller voler les pauvres pour donner
aux riches
j'ai des dettes à mon père et moi je
veux bien travailler avec toi j'ai plein
d'adressent de peau ne sommes pas elle
ne sommes pas et on y va mais irrite
vers la forêt j'ai accepté dans le
groupe je vais te pousser une pièce
aussi coup et on a six travaillent
aujourd'hui à dieu d'abord il faut
travailler dans une banque centrale
les pauvres tout de suite et en plus
j'ai même des bijoux
allez vas y tu sais faire la burqa si on
l'avait notamment berlin est le lien le
dico am j la princesse n'a dit ni mook
saura-t-elle faire la brise vous le
saurez en regardant le prochain épisode
de la dynastie des plumes ou qu ils sont
vraiment obsolète tous les deux obsolète
adjectif qualificatif démodé hors
d'usagé
ouah h 48
[Musique]